das sind bewegende bilder aber vor allen
dingen müssen wir einmal vermitteln was
das für uns alle hier in deutschland
bedeutet wir sind damals nach
afghanistan gegangen um al kaida zu
bekämpfen 20 jahre danach stehen wir im
grunde genau wieder dort
nein wir stehen deutlich schlechter da
als vor 20 jahren denn wir haben die
best bewaffnete islamistische armee der
welt geschaffen die taliban verfügen
jetzt über mehr black hawk hubschrauber
als 164 länder auf der welt inklusive
deutschland wir haben ja beide neben
sprechen hören der gesagt hat die
afghanische armee hat eine luftwaffe die
afghanische armee existiert nicht mehr
diese luftwaffe ist jetzt in händen der
taliban das was wir dort geschaffen
haben ist der ultimative rückzugsort für
islamisten nachdem das kalifat in syrien
der islamische staat der sogenannte
islamische staat gefallen ist haben sich
islamistische terroristen und kämpfer
über die ganze welt versprengt und
verzweifelt nach einem sicheren ort
gesucht und diesen sicheren ort den
haben sie jetzt von westlicher politik
das muss man leider sagen inklusive der
bundesregierung auf dem silbertablett
serviert bekommen wenn man vor 20 jahren
noch sagen konnte dass das was aus
afghanistan hervor gingen nämlich nine
eleven in gewisser weise unvorstellbar
war das unvorstellbar war dass der islam
ist islamismus zu einem globalen sturm
auf die westliche welt ansetzen würde
dann wissen wir dass hier jetzt seit 20
jahren und der unterschied ist dass man
damals quasi einer eher unbekannten und
unterschätzt macht wir sehen jetzt noch
mal die bilder an eine level die gegen
von afghanistan aus die wurden in
afghanistan geplant dass man damals
einer unterschätzten macht dieses land
überlassen hat heute wusste man dass
diese macht nicht unterschätzt ist oder
heute hat man diese werbe wusste man wie
militärisch schlagkräftig und wie
entschlossen und wie radikal diese macht
ist und man hat ihn jetzt ein gesamtes
land inklusive waffen inklusive
militärischen hochtechnologisierten
gerät und inklusiven vollen kassen mit
milliarden euro und dollar aus
steuergeldern aus den usa in deutschland
überlassen
[Musik]